you have more time than you realize I
want to encourage you that your next
level will be accessed by your next
level of discipline and I know that you
don't expect me to be cursing and I hate
to say the d word but you need
discipline and I'm sorry I know like if
kids are around cover their ears but
like we need discipline and your next
level of breakthrough is going to be
accessed on your next level of
discipline but if you have the audacity
to say man I want to create passive
income I want to build a life and a
future around my dreams then you count
the cost and then you pay the price of
the law of sacrifice an uncommon life
requires uncommon choices and habits and
if you want the life that others don't
have you have to do what others won't do